You hear the gallon attarian clarion
call everywhere.
Everything should be equal.
Everything should be equally
distributed.
We should strive for equity.
It's like wrong,
especially if you're a conservative,
wrong.
What we want are just hierarchies of
competence.
Not everyone's a neurosurgeon.
You know,
if your father has a brain tumor,
you probably want a hierarchy of
competence for neurosurgeons so you can
pick the one that's the best so that he
might not die.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for.
For the postmodernists,
there's no hierarchy that isn't based on
power.
Well,
because they think the world runs on
power and that's why they're willing to
use power to get what they want because
it's the only thing they believe in,
but a valid hierarchy of competence.
It's God.
We need those things,
man.
We need the best plumbers.
We need the best contractors.
We need the best.
We knew we need the best carpenters,
we need the best lecturers.
There has to be a hierarchy of quality,
not only so that we know who the best
are and can reward them properly,
but so that we can reward them so they
keep being the best.
It's like you know if,
if you have a great educator,
if you have a great leader,
if you have a great thinker,
you want to reward them so they keep
thinking and they keep educating so they
can tell you something.
It's not a reward for their intrinsic
being.
It's a calculated move on your part to
suck everything out of them that's
valuable as fast as you can.
That's what a hierarchy of competence is
for and the idea is that hierarchies of
competence don't exist is it's so
cynical.
It's such a pathologically cynical idea
and it's actually quite patently untrue
because here's an interesting tidbit
from the psychological literature.
Let's say you want to determine what the
best predictors are for lifetime success
in a Western society.
Well,
what would you hope for?
How about intelligence?
There'd be a good one.
Let's hope the smart people occupied
more positions of complexity,
right?
Because they're smarter.
Do you want it any other way?
Okay,
and then so and that's great.
The number one predictor of
accomplishment in western societies is
intelligence.
So that means the system works.
What's the number to predictor
conscientiousness?
Well,
what's that?
It's a trademark or for hard work.
So who?
Who gets ahead,
smart people who work hard now that
doesn't account for every bit of the
difference between people in terms of
their hierarchical structure because
hierarchies aren't perfect.
They're corrupt.
People get to the top sometimes because
there's psychopathic,
although believe me,
a hell of a lot less than you think
because a psychopath has to keep moving
from place to place because once he
reveals himself as deceitful and
untrustworthy,
he has to go find new soccer's to
fleece.
So the idea that you know,
there's no distinction between a CEO and
a psychopath.
It's like that's only made by someone
who knows nothing about psychopaths be,
knows nothing about ceos and c has
something fundamental against the entire
capitalist structure because it's simply
not true.
Corrupt,
sometimes greedy,
sometimes short,
shortsighted,
sometimes running companies that are
doing their best to auger themselves
into the ground.
And so,
you know,
it's bad people running a dying
organization,
but generally speaking,
it's not the case.
Our hierarchies of competence are
reasonably functional and not only are
they functional,
they're valuable.
We need to know who the competent people
are and we need to reward them.
And even more importantly,
we need to tell young people,
hey,
there's some hierarchies of competence
out there,
like a thousand of them.
Go be a plumber man,
but be a good one.
You know,
being honest.
One B,
I had a plumber once,
you know,
it was the night,
it was the night before we were putting
drywall in our house.
We were redoing a house and he had put
in all the plastic piping,
you know,
and I was going to test,
the joints are supposed to be glued
together with his pipe glue.
Right?
And I said,
I told her I had to test the joints and
he said,
well,
you don't have to test my joints.
They never leak.
And I thought,
yeah,
that's okay.
How about if I test them?
So I went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water,
capping them in the basement like you're
supposed to.
Like half an hour later I had two inches
of water in the basement.
There were 30 leaking joints and that
was the night before the drywallers were
supposed to show up so well.
So he wasn't particularly competent.
That's the point of that story.
But even more so he had put a bunch of
the plastic pipe outside where the
drywall would be.
So it would have been sticking through
the wall.
So I spent a frenetic night,
you know,
sawing through plastic pipe and re
gluing joints so that my.
So that the drywallers could come in.
What's the point?
If you're going to be a plumber,
man,
be a good plumber because otherwise all
you do is go out there and cause
trouble.
And we don't need people to cause more
We need people to solve problems,
you know?
And so you can be a tradesman and you
can be,
you can make a lot of money as a trades
person.
It's a bloody reliable,
honorable,
a forthright,
productive way of making a living and
there is a hell of a lot of difference
between a working man who knows what
he's doing and one who doesn't,
both in terms of skill and ethics.
Right,
and you work with someone who knows what
they're doing.
It's a bloody pleasure.
They tell you what they're going to do,
they tell you how much it will cost.
They go and do it works and you pay them
perfect.
Everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you to.
You listen to these panderers of
egalitarianism,
a gallery,
equity,
and they failed to recognize completely
that there are differences in rank
between people.
It's not such a terrible thing,
man.
Maybe he wouldn't be a great lawyer like
it's certainly possible.
Most people aren't,
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at.
There's lots of hierarchies to attempt
to climb and if you fail in one,
go try and another,
but the point is you're still trying to
aim for the top and what the hell are
you going to do?
If you don't try to aim for the top,
you know,
flap about uselessly and whine about
your life,
it's not helpful.
It will just make you miserable.
You're not reliable to anyone.
You can't help out in a crisis.
It's like so you tell young people,
this is another message for
conservatives like,
I don't care why you're going to do,
but go out there and make something of
yourself for God's sake.
Be An honest person and work and get to
the top of whatever it is that you want
to get to the top of you know,
and,
and stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a
blight.
You know,
and you can tell young people that and
they haven't been told that by anyone
now.
And so the young men are so hungry for
that,
that it's,
it's painful to watch.
They're so relieved when finally someone
finally comes up and says,
Hey,
you know,
you,
you get your act together bit discipline
yourself.
See if you can learn to tell the truth,
concentrate on something for a year or
two.
You could be a bloody world beater.
They think freely.
That's possible.
Wow.
That would be.
That would be interesting.
That might make life or life worth
living.
It's like,
yeah,
it might.
So why don't you go do it now.
That's what the damn universities we're
supposed to be teaching people and
they've forgotten that.
I went to Harvard month ago,
month and a half.
I used to teach there and I talked to a
bunch of students.
You know what I told them?
It's not easy to get into Harvard,
you know,
like you're a Valedictorian if you're at
Harvard and not only are you a
Valedictorian,
you're way better than most people,
at least two other things or you don't
get it.
And so that gets.
I don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me,
not everybody applies.
So it's a very selective school and so
why am I saying that?
It's like these are high quality kids,
so I told them what I just told you.
It's like,
here you are at Harvard.
It's like get yourself educated,
man,
read some books,
learn to talk,
learn to think,
make yourself into something,
get the hell out there and make the
world that put you here happy that you
were put there in that great
institution,
you know,
and they came up to me afterwards and
said,
God,
I wish someone would have told us that
when we were in our first year.
It's like,
Jesus,
why didn't someone tell them that for
God's sake,
it's supposed to be the greatest
university in the world.
Is it so difficult to figure that out?
Well,
it is.
If that is what you want to have happen
in the university,
you want to make cringing milk sops who
whined about being victims while they're
going to ivy league institutions.
Jesus,
it's pathetic.